quitte d'une valeur de 200 € sanction en
cas de refus le point sur le retour de
l'uniforme à l'école est-ce une bonne
idée ou pas dites-nous regardez cette
petite vidéo l'uniforme à l'école c'est
ce que souhaiterait le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui devrait lancer
une grande expérimentation dès 2024
école collège lycée tout se ferait sur
la base du volontariat à Lyon ses
parents eux sont plus ou moins
convaincus ça permet d'avoir un peu plus
d'égalité entre tous les enfants puisque
il y a des enfants qui qui n'ont pas les
mêmes voilà les mêmes moyens
non c'est pas la priorité je pense que
c'est plus une question de d'éducation
de la part des parents la tenue pour
chaque élève serait composée de 5 polo
de pull et deux pantalons concernant le
coût le ministère le chiffrerait à 200 €
par élève comme moi donc c'est pareil
oui alors dites-mous oui c'est le le gé
non mais c'est délirant votre truc et
maintenant non et maintenant on donne un
kit et vous savez le pire cyil le pire
c'est que ça va être valable pour les
sorties à l'extérieur si on les met dans
le règlement intérieur alors maintenant
non mais pour une fois de m'écouter que
j'en moi j'en voilà voilà
aprè il va y avoir des lycéens de 17 ans
qui vont sortir de l'école en activité
scolaire tous en uniforme mais vous
délirez
total ta copine revient de Londres ils
sont comme ça à
londresire c'est
géal laiss les réactionnaires mais pas
vous s' vous plaît laisser la parler
parlez lui parce que je peux plus là là
tu as des élèves où il y a plus de
combat de se dire euh là lui il a une
meilleure marque que moi de mettre la
pression aux parents pour la rentrée de
dire ouais mais lui il aura ces baskets
là moi je les aurais pas il y a pas
cette distinction là déjà au niveau
social après il y a une question aussi
de praticité c'estàd que tu te réveilles
le matin bah tuabiller tous les jours de
la même manière et et tu es égal à tes à
tes coéquipiers tes tes collègues et moi
je trouve que c'est super c'est super et
en plus de ça je trouve ça je trouve ça
très joliès tu pas un écolo tu es un
écolo ouais à chaque fois tu nous vends
ton
écologie les
vêtements po les vêtements c'est ce le
plus c'est bien pour ça que vous en
changez
rarement et ben là pour le coup et ils
auront moins de vêtements parce que là
les jeunes qui ont dans leur
plac non non ils auront quatre modèles
ils le changeront mais c'est ça fait
clairement un économie un économie de
vêtements donc pour un écologiste c'est
un aspect écologique ça auelà de ça
est-ce qu'on peut parler du harcèlement
tu as pas l'impression qu'il y aura un
petit peu moins d'harcèlement avec ces
uniformes là just parce que ça alors
déjà déjà il y aura pas harcèlement sur
le physique et en plus le physique
vestimentaire et en plus de ça ça fait
une cohésion de groupe ça veut dire que
là il il se ils se retrouvve dans une
espèce de confrériie où il ils vont se
sentir solidaire entre eux c'est con
hein mais c'est l'apparence ils vont se
dire bah on est tous ensemble et en fait
ça va créer un truc social je trouve
important moi rapidement après désol je
parler je me suis fait harceler quand
j'avais 13 ans parce que je m'habillais
d'une façon spéciale je me rendais pas
compte moi je m l' JAV sur mes jeans
j'avais des looks bon parfois voyez même
la veste aujourd'hui ça continue bref si
j'avais un uniforme peut-être que
j'aurais eu moins de raison de me faire
harceler donc ça c'est quand même
quelque chose de positif absolument non
mais c'est la seule chose positive dans
un
océan le coû
financier depuis que dit c'était le côté
fort le
droit et le
copilote
[Applaudissements]
pas d'accord
allezz moi j'ai toujours été contre et
je vais rester contre l'uniforme parce
que là vous me faites voir d'une photo
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est une
école privée ils sont beaux j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit payé avec on
parle de 200 € il y a 100 millions
d'élèvres va trouver où l'argent c'est
c'est la collectivité qui va et elle
trouve où la collectivité dans les
impôts des Français la collectivité
c'est pas une société récolte déjà ça va
faire la collectivité et vous me parlez
de deux pulls j'ai regardé parce que moi
comme je suis contre l'uniforme j'ai
regardé deux pulls C polos deux
pantalons il y a 5 jours dans la semaine
donc si perd un pantalon fait comment et
cetera et cetera et Kelly elle a fait le
bon exemple elle a dit les baskets Kelly
les baskets ils seront comment il y a
pas de discrimination il y a pas de
basket he dans dans vos 200 € il y a pas
de basket le manteau quand il fait froid
le mec il va venir avec une doudoune
d'une grande marque et l'autre il va
venir avec une doudoune Carrefour ou Tex
ou Kabi il y aura pas de
discrimination
discrimination vous cherchez des trucs
dans les autres pays regardez lui Steven
ah il est beau mais qui c'est qui a payé
ça Steven je pense pas que ce soit je
pense pas que ce soit l'état on a des
gens ici qui viennent il peuvent pas
soigner parce qu'ils ont des cancers on
a des gens ici
qui
dém pr tu crois pas que la va préférer
acheter une tenue dans l'année même si
ch que 15 paires de basket que le petit
va demander parce qu' pas de ses enfants
pour le plaisir de ses enfants bien sû
le jour o un enfant on verra comment tu
va l'AB
dansnen tu sais très bien les parents le
plaisir d'habiller leurs enfants qui soi
bien hab àécole co mais là on parle de
10 à 12 millions faire écomies à 12
millions d'élèves
arr écomies à 12 millions d'élèves à 200
balles faites le calcul prenez une
calculatrice faites 12 millions 200 €
exceptionn vous me faites chier ça
marchera pas le truc ça marchera pas je
suis pressé qu'il tu m'entends là oh par
que vous êes fou 5 polo de pull pour
faire la semaine de P tuis mais moi
j'étais bien moi à l'école sans un fore
je mais c fois le même tshirt c'est
normal tu te faisais pas harceler mais
non comment tu sais c'est toi qui dit
derère foisas dit c'était toi qui GTA
pasra tu mets sur ton je tu fais des
trucs c'est g chch c'est bon les gars
c'est bon vous avez sououé on dirait
qu'on parle d'un truc de ouf gonfl mais
ou c'est alors moi je me souviens on
avait déjà parlé j'étais contre j'en ai
parlé avec ma femme finalement je
vais je vais dire non et je pense que
moi d'abord est-ce qu' a une fois où tu
vas garder ton
[Applaudissements]
av je te kiffe je tee pas borné il
écoute les
arguments Mo je suis vrai tu vois donc
pour le coup pour moi actuellement il y
a une priorité pour l'école c'est de
remettre dans les normes
c'estàdire de les réparer de protéger
les professeurs d'améliorer les
conditions des élèves et une fois qu'il
aura tout ça habz comme vous voulez avec
une
CR VO m à
la mais tu nous JIS ai top parce que des
débat c'est idéal qu les discrimination
et comme l' dit Kelly pour la cohésion
du groupe c'est parfait beso
me fâche
pas
SAS perdu
[Applaudissements]
ton vasy contrôler des
là je peux plus les voir oui on va les
punir cyil ceux qui ne m TR pas vont
être punis vous vous rendez compte
pas ah si c'est dans le projet de loi
punition
n m par question de la religion la
religion c'est ai hyper important vu
tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ça me
semblerait normal que quand je regarde
une classe entière je vois des élèves
qui sont tous pareil je me dis pas elle
elle elle porte ça donc ça veut dire que
potentiellement elle est musulmane lui
porte ça donc je me dis que peut-être
qu'il est catholique lui il est non là
je vois une
bande mais qu'est-ce que tu pass il sera
puni c'est dans le vous pleurez parce
qu'on met pas les enfant on va punir
unfant par
pas c'est pas truc tu conis Ren tatoi
ttoi secondes
fatig même oublie son P il aura un polo
il va pas venir à
pooi mon fils il est dans une école il a
l'uniformeè que tu es tu crois tu crois
quand il oublie son pull mais non mais
taistoi c'est la
base France pas arrêtez de RVER les
me économiesce que tu res ça coûte moins
cher l'uniforme
moi tu races comme Conner je et quand il
oubl l'uniforme tu crois tu crois que
mon fils il dis quoi il sont
[Rires]
pasis
là oui non mais frère vous êtes con
quoiend je
dis
ser me quoi quand ils vont dire
l'uniforme le gars il y a une tolérance
dans va mettre un truc bleu qui
ressemble à l'uniforme ça va
passer vir en truc ble alors élèvoubl
bien s mais ça Arve
redescends je pas Moné Mo mais je te dis
là tu prends la tête pour rien tu dis
des colories ver vous allez voir et
allez faire des UV tous les deux vous me
faites
[Rires]
chier c pas les bonbons qu'estce que tu
veux non mais honnêtement depuis tout à
l'heure Gill tu as pas dit un seul
argument qui valait quoi que ce soit
d'habitude tu arrives à argumenter mais
là tu es à la ramasse quoi ouais c'est
vrai il a raison complètement dingue
enfin on a l'impression on est les seuls
censés avec Raymond on a l'impression
les accus alle cré tu as changé de
couple remets-toi ta coupe ta coupe
pourrie
là j'allis créer des
enfants ben laissez-moi répondre à Hugo
man à chaque fois vous ramenez votre
truc vous dites 100 fois la même chose
avec votre content j'en parce que ce qui
ce qui me navre c'est qu'il faut que te
dire 100 fois les choses pour que tu les
comprennes une fois c'est compliqué
quand même pas envie de les comprendre
surtout que G tu as dit un truc grave
quand même tu as dit la seule chose qui
est vrai dans ce que vous dites c'est
pour le harcèlement c'est
pas et pour la
religion est-ce que je gueule sur les
gens
moi pas les gars l'uni non frèrear là
j'arrête là 2 minutes non frère je te
dis la vérité je sais pas si tu as fait
ce weekend frère vraiment tu as l'air
très
gtif tu as l'air vraiment trèstigé là
j'ai golerie avec vous on mais là frère
je suis quand même un peu inqui ah bon
non frère j'éta à la cave et je suis
remonté de la cave j'ai rien fait
[Applaudissements]
extraordinaire non mais frère regardee
regarde dans le plan regarde on est à
côté frère c'est un truc de ouf frère on
dirait
vraiment pas les mêmes origine non plus
oui mais je pense qu' là te reste
vraiment je pense que
Max max 15
jours max jour fais Noël
avant av no passe Noël ah B ben merci
c'est génial super je pense 26 décembre
je vais devoir revenir d'urgence à
Paris je vais devoir annuler mes
vacances avec tes conneries
allez c'est la fin du approche
d'ailleurs pour ça c'était la transition
c'est pour la transition les chér on
voir ce qu'en pens les téléspectateurs
déjà ah oui alors voilà voilà merci
merci je vous aime les Chéries merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci Gill Verde
façon il faut jamais suivre Gill Verdez
hein ça va mon ginou mais ça va très
bien ça va vous allez créer des enfants
robots avec vos
truc diff
libèrebent pas non plus vous l'adorez
peut-être moi jeadore oua vous vous
l'adorez maisah partez ensemble ti avec
plaisir tous ensemble tous
ensemblez tous partir en vacances là au
non pas offr de la prod moi jees pas
tous quand
même mon dire on découte pas les autres
quoi mon dire tu partiras avec moi toi
avec plaisir en
[Rires]
business j'adore